i want to end the show today uh with
three videos from aoc and i think i'm
going to cover these in a very special
way just with one line each uh because
i'm going to let aoc the wonder woman of
intellectual genius i'm going to let her
words stand on their own video one
well i certainly don't think it's
healthy that exxon mobil lobbyists are
bragging about how many senators
democrat and republican that they get to
have spee on speed dial and enjoy
exclusive access to shaping the contours
of this quote-unquote bipartisan
infrastructure bill i don't think that
that's healthy at all i think the role
of dark money and or and the fossil fuel
lobby is extremely unhealthy for our
democracy
but the fact of the matter is is that
we've got the people on on our side and
this is what we continue to say you know
they have money these lobbyists and and
special interests have money but we've
got people the buildback better act has
popular support and even going above and
beyond that the green new deal has
popular support even among republicans
and independents and so what what people
i think are united behind is the
acknowledgement that climate change is
human caused that the burning of fossil
fuels and the continued construction of
fossil fuel infrastructure like what
we're seeing with line three in
minnesota must be confronted if we're
going to create a better future for
ourselves yeah the green new deal has
popular support even among republicans
and independents aoc you're a liar
next when we talk about um
the law that was passed in texas
we know that anti-choice bills
are not about being pro-life because if
they were about being pro-life
then the republican party would support
frankly an agenda that helps
guaranteed health care that helps ensure
that people who do give birth that don't
have the resources
to care for a child can have that care
for a child so we know that none of this
is about life
none of this is about supporting life
what this is about is controlling
women's bodies and controlling people
who are not cisgender men this is about
making sure that someone like me as a
woman or any menstruating person in this
country cannot make decisions over their
own body and people like governor abbott
and mitch mcconnell want to have more
control over over a woman's body than
that woman or that person has over
themselves and what what that shares in
uh in
you know what that shares with rape
culture is that sexual assault is about
the abuse of power and sexual assault is
about asserting control over another
person and the ease
with which these men seek to do that to
other people
is atrocious
aoc in that video in case you weren't
playing paying attention called women
people who give birth then she called
them women and then she called them any
menstruating person
thus aoc you're a transphobic [ __ ] clip
three
yes now listen if you live in california
there's probably a ballot in your
mailbox on a recall election please find
that thing
vote no stick that sucker right back in
your mailbox because the options are
back
aoc just get the [ __ ] out of my state
you buffoon we don't want you here we
don't care what you think and we're
going to do what we think is right but
because you are so
rabidly against a decent black man
becoming governor of the great state of
california the once great state i should
say
you are a right-wing
racist white supremacist congratulations
aoc